alors jean marie on vous a souvent
reproché d'être vulgaire vous en avez
rigolé vous même vous ai fait un sketch
que j'adore en disant moi ils m'ont
laissé le vulgaire tu connais ce sketch
que devrait assez les grandes causes qui
est mon sketch jeux préférés de jean
marie bigard alors on va voir si c'est
vrai en fait si vous êtes vraiment
vulgaire on va faire un test
[Musique]
est ce que vous regardez parfois le foot
avec des potes en buvant de la bière
alors
non mais je foute non parce que le foot
c'est nul ouais ouais les joueurs de
foot sont formidables il joue vachement
mieux que les joueurs de foot 10 à 20
ans tantôt oui je regarde pas le foot
parce que les règles du foot sont
lamentables et donc je regarde le rugby
le handball le méchant je regarde tous
les sports qui ont changé leurs règles
je dirais le foot a gardé des règles
paléontologique et il est lamentable il
inspire la violence et il ya de la
violence dans les tribunes parce que ce
sport est nulle d'axer leur seul souhait
c'est le seul sport qui peut faire 0 0
oui c'est dire aucun but marqué tu
prennes sport qui fait 0 0 c'est bien la
raison un mec a passé le dernier
adversaire il ya plus personne il n'est
pas dans la surface de réparation il a
dépassé tout le monde à la loyale on lui
prend la can d'ailleurs le mec qui prend
la can à mon avis devrait être interdit
de foot pendant dix ans dont 33 en
france parce qu'il fait un acte
antisportif il est récompensé parce
qu'il n'est pas dans la surface de
réparation
donc ça va faire un coup franc donc tous
les [ __ ] qui sont avec ses tanks
usagers à ce tournant sur un char se met
entre le but et le match aller on répare
une occasion de but par zéro occasion de
but c'est à dire que la justice est
récompensé en revanche un mec est dans
la surface de réparation
tous les défenseurs sont entre lui et le
but il n'a aucune chance de marquer un
but il ressort de la surface de
réparation
est-ce qu'il veut rien à faire là le
même au cul les plus grands la kanaky on
m en trois ans d'interdiction de foot
aussi et là ya penalty sait on répare
zéro occasion de but par une vraie
occasion de mieux que ce sport est
lamentable il faudrait au foot tant que
le foot ne changera pas c'est comme au
rugby tu imagines avant le rugby tu as
vu les paquets que ça faisait maintenant
on peut plus garder un peu plus garder
la balle on oblige il a libéré tout de
suite ça donne des matches formidables
c'est bien vous devrez interdit la vie
de chaque d'amsterdam a compris qu'il
fallait remonter très vite pour mettre
l'adversaire hors jeu il devrait plus y
avoir de hors-jeu au foot on devrait
jouer à 18 joueurs avec des temps morts
de façon à pouvoir changer par paquet de
6 les joueurs et aucun hors jeu sur tout
le terrain et les scores de foot ça
devrait être deux 12/08 20-16 ça serait
toujours la meilleure équipe qui
gagnerait et on pourrait voir le talent
des nouveaux joueurs de foot mais ça ça
ne se fait plus et voilà pourquoi je ne
regarde pas le foot parce que il a des
règles lapied se fait
ailleurs
je tiens juste à
temps à tort sauf la serbie en finale de
coupe du monde quand tu vois une finale
de coupe du monde qui se finit au
penalty qu est-ce qu on peut en penser
jean marie te dire pourquoi ils sont pas
aux dés à la fin exactement mais tes
chiens chercher tout ça
bien
non je ne pense pas que le problème est
réglé les banques soient qui regarde pas
le foot et en buvant de la bière c'est
parce que tu m'aies branché sur une
question éthique qui faisait penser que
tu donnes tu pensais qu'elle était très
con et que tu faisais un bon kit a
répondu les 5 min le baby alors est-ce
que tu m'aider survêt le week-end
ducasse a décidé de faire chier de sa
tâche à merveille chez pathé ça que
j'aime bien chez toi je mets un survêt
aussi bête que ta question je
m'assurerai que quand je fais du sport
par les levées du sport tous les jours
et je n'en remets pas spécialement le
week end bon d'accord il ya là l'idée de
week end et de jours de semaines n'a pas
lieu d'accord pour les danses que voilà
un week end et jours de semaine c'est la
même joie la joie lie tout le temps
alors vous reculez est ce que tu es ce
que tu es ce que tu te casses les
couilles 100 fois par géo pas leurs noms
mais je sais pas moi je tiens
les couilles 100 fois par jour je vais
signer au bout d'un moment
est-ce que ok j'étais mort et j'arrive
je me gratte desgouilles tous les matins
ce que ne peut pas faire nadine parce
qu'elle n'a pas de couilles qu'est-ce
qui se tient bien le terrain et de 10 en
même temps c'est mon interview non mais
j'ai compris
et les français notre moi qui réponds
heureusement touché jamais l'europe je
suis passé avant tout à dix mois
est-ce que je suis né des questions qu
est toute la france rougis de ta conduit
est ce que tu es ce que tu justement
justement on y arrive à la conduite est
ce que tu pense franchement que les
femmes sont incapables de faire un
créneau
jédir
je vais si je te dis oui un petit peu
gérard toutes les chiennes de garde aux
cubains je vais te dire que sûrement que
c'est moins toi il ya moins de pilotes
automobiles moi je fais de la course à
mes heures perdues il ya sûrement moins
deux pilotes que
femmes que d'hommes les refaire un peu
la mécanique les hommes savent vachement
moins bien faire des enfants que les
femmes j'en ai même qu'il va te rendre
fou est ce que tu as déjà pensé à se
laisser pousser le catogan
un match dans
la fosse mais aussi
une agression est ce que tu connais pas
bouffer chez buffalo grill non
si je vais vous fait chez malgré ça fait
un si je compte à la fin si tu attends
de points et je vais vous faire parce
que
figure toi et tu dieu sait si je suis en
colère après les 35 heures ouais surtout
vis-à-vis de la gastronomie vis-à-vis de
l'hôtellerie en général away et d'une
catastrophe mondiale on est le pays de
la bouffe et moi qui suis en tournée
toute ma vie eh bien il faut que tu
arrives à table entre 12h30 et 1h30
sinon tu bouges fun boost paix dans le
pays de la bouffe imposés 35 heures
soient vains sauf à l'hôtel du bon arbre
à dakhla le grill tu arrives à 15 heures
on arrive à 4 heures je vais les 35 ans
arrive à 15h tu étais bien reçu ils ont
atteint très bon système je crois que
c'est des français qui ont fait ça je me
suis monsieur cds français
ils ont monté une chaîne de trucs ou
moins tu peux manger correctement et à
peu près n'importe quelle heure
et vingt il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'endroits où tu peut bouffer que tu
veux en france dans le pays de la bouffe
tu la trouves comment amélie mauresmo
pour un mec
[Rires]
je trouve qu amélie mauresmo je la suis
si jamais le jouer un match je
l'encouragent cocorico juive asie jeu
puisqu'elle gagne je ne vais pas besoin
que j'ai de savoir qu'elle préférait les
filles ça m'était totalement illégal sa
sexualité je m'en fous ces humains comme
elle veut je n'avais pas besoin de le
savoir est en tout cas je l'encouragent
parce que je trouve que c'est une super
bonne je vois que tu es pas vulgaire
tout le monde le sait maintenant et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu